recently while i was googling around i
came across this article about hungary
or rather an american guy living in
hungary and his experiences
being hungarian and having grown up in
hungary naturally peaked my interest
three depressing realities about living
in eastern europe by matt forney
dated 30th of november 2017. in january
of this year i packed my things and got
on a one-way flight to budapest hungary
to start my life anew after nearly two
years of living in chicago
do i like it here mostly don't get me
wrong
hungary and everywhere else in eastern
europe is a massive upgrade over the us
in everything that matters the streets
are clean and safe
what the women are cute and loose and
the cost of living can't be beat
well as long as you have an american
salary i guess but after nearly a year
in [ __ ] paradise
the bloom is of the rose [ __ ] paradise
what
here are some annoying realities of
living in eastern europe that you'll
just have to get used to if you're an
expat
expat huh keep that word in mind folks
but who is matt forney and what is
return of kings
first the website itself it has a
helpful about section where they write
turn of kings is a block for
heterosexual masculine men
okay it's meant for a small but vocal
collection of
men in america today who believe men
should be masculine and women should be
feminine
okay reserve kings aims to assure the
return of the masculine man
in a world where masculinity is being
increasingly punished and shamed in
favor of creating an androgynous and
politically correct society
that allows women to assert superiority
and control
over men and jesus victim complex much
sadly yesterday's masculinity is today's
misogyny
the site intends to be a safe space on
the web for those who don't agree with
the direction of that western culture is
headed
if you're new check out the top women
and homosexuals are strongly discouraged
from commenting here
all right return of king's community
believes the ideas and beliefs
here are based on neo-masculinity here
are a few of its principle tenets i mean
are generally different blah blah blah
manuela plato monogamy blah blah blah
best traditions rituals testosterone
woman's values fertility and beauty
gender roles good socialism feminism
cultural marxism and social justice
warriorism aim to destroy the family
unit
decrease the fertility rate and
impoverish the state through large
welfare entitlements
yeah so this is return of kings kind of
yikesy traditional conservative but with
a pickup artist
veneer on it founded by roush v a
particularly notorious and toxic
pickup artist i should say so what
articles does this website has to offer
two signs to identify a liberal in
disguise by edgar through
september 30th 2018 1.
they support women's rights i hold the
claim that allowing females to vote was
a rotten call of judgment by
men and to this day there are
conservatives in quotation marks who
support this decision
personally i find it anti-conservative
and pro-liberal to allow women to vote
that doesn't equate to hating them but
rather recognizing they lack logic
which by their very nature means they
cannot vote in accordance with law and
order
safety and security it isn't complex
unless of course you're a female
in which you may not possess the
intellect to grasp the overall societal
implications of such a manner
conservatism has a foundation it does
not stray from tradition
in the ancient world men dominated and
women submitted or were put in their
place if they were too disobedient
i mean far be it from me to king shame
but edgar my boy you're making it real
difficult for me right now
any man or woman who supports women's
rights to vote
in terms of political power is
liberal-minded beware of those prancing
around right winged circles
who still hold this delusional
libertarian-esque mentality
they are not conservative in their
hearts of hearts and here i gotta say
english isn't complex unless of course
you're edgar
in which case you may not possess the
intellect to grasp the overall
grammatical implications of such a
language
moving on let's look at what our friend
matt forney has been up to
how donald trump is inspiring a
masculine renaissance in america
why electing donald trump is the only
way to preserve freedom of speech in
america
make no mistake if hillary clinton
becomes president
she will kill free speech in america if
you value the freedoms bequeathed to you
by the constitution
you have no choice but to support donald
trump his persuasiveness and openly
nationalist platform
make him the only candidate capable of
halting and possibly reversing
the left's destruction of our nation the
simple reality is that freedom of speech
in america
as well as the other freedoms we take
for granted only came about because of
the us was founded by
whites free speech the rule of law and
the entire framework of our society
evolved
out of the unique culture of europe
starting with the ancient greeks and
developed by the theologians of the
reformation and the philosophers of the
enlightenment oh you mean that
philosophical movement espousing liberty
progress tolerance and fraternity the
thing modern liberalism is based on
the movement that mary wollstonecraft
was a part of who according to wikipedia
was one of england's earliest feminist
philosophers she argued for a society
based on reason
and that women as well as men should be
treated as rational beings
but of course our friend met has no
[ __ ] idea when far writers like him
talk about
european culture and european history
what they imagine
is white people who first wear togas and
then armor
and then lung coats together with
powdered wigs and then eventually we get
to the present time where feminists and
sjws ruin everything
the only way freedom of speech can be
preserved in the us is if
whites remain a majority and donald
trump is the only candidate who's
fighting to ensure this
hillary clinton will do the opposite
flood this country with foreign peasants
who will give electoral heft to her
campaign and destroy freedom in america
who these immigrants am i right just
like wanting to go to other countries
willy-nilly and you know live
there and use their social services good
thing you're a [ __ ] expat and not an
immigrant dude oh wow you touched that
bullet
moving on with the articles google's
anti-white sketch of the juno mission
team shows how evil the company has
become
and it's a google doodle depicting the
people who worked on the juno mission
and on the right there's the panel and
people on the panel are all white
and the doodle contains brown people as
well and met rights
however falsely depicting a team of
white men as a multi-ethnic multi-gender
team is apparently acceptable
yeah don't forget guys the left are the
real snowflakes they get triggered over
[ __ ] like police
brutality while ignoring the real issues
such as
brown pixel people on the google main
page for like a day or so
why you should shun girls who support
abortion my argument for shunning girls
who are pro-abortion is based in
self-preservation regardless of her
other apparent qualities if a girl is in
favor in abortion
there is evil dwelling in her soul if
you let her into your life she will do
her best to
ruin you and bring you down to her level
how to register to vote for donald trump
why donald trump's immigration speech
was a massive success
three reasons why you should apply for a
job in the trump administration
unite the right rally in charlottesville
shut down by city government
and their violent leftist allies and for
those of you not up to date
charlottesville was this far-right rally
counter-protest
which i should say against the removal
of the confederate general robert e lee
statue
that ended in a domestic terrorist
attack when james alex fields jr
a participant of the united right rally
and a neo-nazi and white supremacist
rammed his vehicle into a line of
counter protesters
killing one and injuring 19. meet the
billionaire jewish family funding
breitbart and milo unopolis
while return of kings has no ill will
towards milo or breitbart we believe it
is important that people know how
they're funded
milo and breitbart are not an organic
nationalist resistance but are being
used to push the agenda of a wealthy
jewish family
well this guy went down a [ __ ] rabbit
hole holy [ __ ]
and now let's circle back to the
original article three depressing
realities about living in eastern europe
let's find out what matt thinks is so
depressing over here
one many basic services are horrible and
here he spends three paragraphs bitching
about the postal services
when dhl failed to deliver a box of
nutritional supplements
i had to ride all the way to the end of
one metro line take two separate trams
then walk to their headquarters for 20
minutes to pick it up
holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] trials and
tribulations you have to go through dude
walk for for what 20 minutes holy [ __ ]
how did you survive and well jokes aside
dude it sounds like you need to develop
your discipline
because if you're like most men there's
a gap between your intentions and your
actions
you know what you need to do to get what
you want but you have difficulty in
following through
okay so what other tribulations were you
forced by life to go through
in another example i once went to a
vodafone store to top up my phone plan
20 minutes before closing time
and was told that they might not have
time to do it
even though the store was empty and
topping up takes about
3 minutes oh man the herculean tasks you
face every day
2. convenience is middling to
non-existent
i didn't expect europe to be full of
24-hour walmarts where i could just
wander in at 3 in the morning in my
boxers and do my grocery shopping
however europe is missing a lot of
comforts that americans take for granted
for example sunday shopping is severely
restricted in hungary with most stores
closed
oh yes this unpopular measure that was
cancelled since then which was
originally instituted by hungary's
conservative right-wing government
officially so that people can spend more
time with their family
similarly europeans love to nickel and
dine people
and many things that are free in the u.s
cost money over here
for example not only do you have to pay
for plastic bags when you go shopping
you have to bag your own groceries like
a slave
you have to bag your own groceries like
a slave
oh god dude the [ __ ] masculinity is
just like
shining through here truly a descendant
of [ __ ] leonidas himself
you have to pay to use a shopping cart
though you get refunded when you're done
you have to pay for catch-up when you go
to mcdonald's you even have to pay to
use the bathroom in many places even at
restaurants where you already bought
something
i like being able to go out and buy
groceries at 10 at night if i need to
and i don't like having to carry a dozen
coins in my pocket in case i need to use
the can when i'm out
i definitely don't like having to bag my
groceries
because that's what retail workers are
for and also because i forget to bring
it back when i go shopping half the time
well it sounds like you do need that
discipline anyway let's step back for a
bit
and take a look at this thing from a
distance on one hand matt is complaining
about all these leftists bringing up
issues such as
inequality racism sexism and privilege
while he writes articles for a far-right
pickup artist website where he complains
in front of thousands of people
about the minor inconveniences he had
suffered in eastern europe but if you
live in hungary and your biggest problem
is that you have to bag your own
groceries at the store
or having to put a coin into the
shopping cart you are in fact
extremely and almost offensively
privileged and the worst part is this is
so natural for you
that you don't even realize it when this
article was written
the average annual wages adjusted for
purchasing power parity in hungary
were one-third of the us's and if you're
a single working person in budapest the
city
is unaffordable to you even if you're
making above average money
so it would be pretty difficult to live
out this treadcon stay-at-home wife
existence there because it's just not an
option
both of you have to work you know it's
pretty hard to be the traditional
masculine breadwinner alpha male when
two-thirds of your salary go to rent
but now let's go on to the spicier parts
of the article
which is number three degeneracy is
increasing
and there's a picture of a pretty nice
tattoo here it's the it's the hungarian
folk tales series that was very popular
on tv
it's a pretty nice tattoo it's very
culturally traditional hungarian
so matt writes don't get me wrong the
most degenerate day you'll have in
hungary
is better than an average day in the us
open homosexuality is either
non-existent or badly noticeable in
eastern europe and women on average are
better looking and more feminine here
dude what's your problem with gay people
like they're literally the only
demographic that will
not be competition to you the more gay
guys there are the better your chances
but of course he's just using this
pickup artist thing as a vehicle for his
far right views so
however globalism's effects are
increasingly evident even in this corner
of the world
for example in hungary tattoos piercings
and cotton candy colored hair are
becoming more prevalent among young
women
uh matt i'm sorry hold on a second i
think you made a mistake there uh
what you meant to write is i have a
strong feeling in me
that in hungary tattoos piercings and
cotton candy colored hair are becoming
more prevalent among young women
this is what you meant budapest has an
increasing number of bars and cafes with
tattoo parlors on site so you can get a
dragonfly stamped on your ass while you
enjoy a cup of coffee
hungarian women are also starting to get
fat okay which becomes obvious if you
cross the border into ukraine
the women suddenly gain two points of
attractiveness and lose 20 pounds on
average
once again keep in mind if he was honest
here he would have begun
every sentence with i feel like this is
not any sort
of evidence or empirical study or data
this is his feelings we're listening to
right now his subjective impression from
a very limited perspective
at this point he spent less than a year
here he doesn't speak the language and i
guess he never left budapest or just
very rarely
and by the way in 2017 hungary was the
third most obese country in europe
with 26.4 of its population classified
as obese
only out done by turkey and the uk and
this number in ukraine is only 2.3
percent lower so
you know excuse me matt if i don't
entirely trust your intuitions over here
similarly tinder once one of the easiest
ways to meet women in eastern europe has
significantly dropped off in quality
over the past year
in budapest women on tinder have become
increasingly flaky refusing to answer
messages and using the app to gain
attention
from men and i'd like to draw attention
to his phrasing here
it's not that women don't answer they
refuse to answer
or you know maybe they just found your
articles online who knows but you make
it sound that
women in your opinion have an obligation
to answer to your messages
this kind of attitude being a staple on
or slash nice guys
smartphone addiction and online
attention whoring have also been on the
increase in eastern europe meaning that
meeting girls is only going to get more
difficult as time wears on
though the further east you go the
slower these trends are occurring i
don't mean to sound negative
i've enjoyed my time in hungary so far
and would not even entertain the thought
of moving back to the us
despite having to bag my own groceries
the quality of life in eastern europe is
incredible
for you and i'm grateful that i'm able
to live out here
but anyone who thinks that this part of
the world is all sunshine and [ __ ]
will be sorely disappointed
yeah yeah they don't realize they have
to pay for the toilet yet
you just wait you starry eyed naive
american immigrants i mean sorry expats
the reason i find this article
fascinating is because matt here is
guilty of all the stereotypes he assigns
to other people he doesn't like
he immigrates to another country and
then berates it for not adhering to his
ultra-conservative norms
and condemns its people for being too
degenerate for his pure tastes
meanwhile he lives in an inner-city
bubble living the life of hedonism
and [ __ ] about minor inconveniences
like a baby but of course he isn't part
of the problem
it's all these immigrants these brown
people these sjws these muslims these
feminists these socialists these
communists
but if people like him just took a
minute pulled their heads out of their
own asses
and just stopped looking at the world
through this
lens of entitlement and petulance
they would perhaps see how [ __ ]
ridiculous they are and how much of a
belligerent [ __ ] they act like
and maybe they would change for the
better and back their own groceries
without complaining until then
met and people like you please just go
home
eastern europe has enough problems
without you and honestly if you want to
live here
first you need to learn to respect the
local culture thank you for watching if
you have any input please let me know in
the comments otherwise
i'll see you next time and like
subscribe all that
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you